my sister texted me yesterday and
they're like buying a house she is a
full-time job she's a teacher she's
incredible she's nine months pregnant
teacher - I can't wait for her to get
pregnant she has this like really cute
boyfriend they're moving in together
I can't wait this sounds like you're
talking about yourself I wish yeah do
you want to be very handsome man I kind
of do I keep letting him come in me what
what get pregnant like tomorrow I think
so I don't know
you want a kid right now Karen yeah and
I think I can have one I know you could
but like I have a dog Karen we gotta go
to break okay my god dr. Rees is coming
in we'll be right back with dr. Ruth
after this I cannot wait Karen Feehan
dr. Ruth will get into all of this
[Music]
and we're back at you up with Nikki
Glaser I am so very excited for our
guest today I don't even know that I've
been this excited for a guest in the
history of this show dr. Ruth is here
with us from her new documentary ask dr.
Ruth you know dr. Ruth as the world
renowned sex therapist TV personality
author of over 40 books is that true
Pierre he wants to know such luck no he
here I cannot retire he is your
communications manager correct director
of communications right your right-hand
man minister of communication and he
can't retire because you won't and we
need to get dr. or some water I don't
know why this is that's taking so long
get this woman anything she wants
because she is a national a world
treasure I cannot tell you how inspiring
this movie was to me I watched it last
night the movie is ask dr. Ruth it's the
new Hulu documentary premieres Saturday
June 1st on Hulu and it is in theaters
May 3rd
may I recommend going to see it in
theaters it is a is a beautiful
documentary it's there's animation in it
but it's just it's it's beautiful and I
cried multiple times and I just loved it
and how was it for you about making this
documentary yeah I like to hear that
that you cried and you laughed I laughed
so much Ryan White is make it yes it was
a brilliant filmmaker and Rafi Momoa is
the producer and first I said no then I
watched the films that they have done
Rafi did a film no place on earth that
resonated with me because that's the
story of my life
mm-hmm that when I was sent out of Nazi
Germany I was fortunate that I was in
Switzerland because there was no place
on earth for Jews yeah and then I
watched Ryan's movies the keepers
oh yeah and all of his movies the
proposition
about gay rights to my and I thought
okay the time has come I'm now going to
be 91 yes and I'm going to talk about my
background especially to tell people
that the Holocaust did happen those
people say in heaven and those people
who are Holocaust deniers who said you
know it didn't happen and some people
say they have all the cost 14 don't talk
about it oh my god and in today's world
with anti-semitism on the rise and with
other issues of human rights I said I
have to do that documentary and I'm very
happy the way it worked out I really
learned a lot about your experience
through you were an orphan of the
Holocaust is how you describe it you
were a survivor or an orphan of the
Holocaust that was sent to an orphanage
by your parents and you say there's a
amazing quote in the documentary where
you say your parents gave you life twice
when they brought you into this world
did you you watch it very carefully
because once and when they sent me on a
king that transport with a group of
children to Switzerland that's how I'm
alive yes that was the other time and
then I wanted to make sure that people
know that that was a sacrifice because
if they had not sent me to Switzerland
and if Switzerland hadn't accepted me I
wouldn't be alive the children who went
to Holland Belgium and France did not
make it great and there were 10,000
children who went to England despite the
fact that it was before World War two
and they were very dark clouds on the
horizon so I never I don't talk about
politics right somebody who talks about
sex for morning tonight yes has to stay
away except I changed my mind now I do
talk about how upset I am when I see
children beings
for ages from their parents mm-hmm cuz
that's my experience and I say how upset
I am if abortion would become illegal
mm-hmm because then only women with
money could obtain an abortion because
they could go to Europe and the others
will resort to abortionist and to court
Angus yeah and how upset I am about
funding for Planned Parenthood so there
are three issues they despite the fact
that I don't vote yes I'm an American
citizen I for just every election
however I do not talk about politics
somebody who talks about orgasms and her
actions all the time has to stay away I
learned that from you our president
doesn't seem to have a problem yeah you
can talk I don't talk I really do admire
that about you and and and I'm someone
that I talk very openly about sex as
well and I learned a lot from you about
having it for people to take you
seriously about sex you need to have
other boundaries I mean I talk very
openly about my own sex life you seem to
have not gone that route as much because
you are young and I'm old so you can
talk about you when you were young and I
hope I hope that you're talking about
your sex life yeah that you tell them to
use contraception yeah it use
contraception okay yes and to be careful
yes
ain't careful and and and hopefully to
find a relationship and to get married
yeah that's the tough one I can't really
tell people that I yeah it's very
difficult no question I'm coming with
Pierre since he can't retire we oughta
published a new edition of sex for
dummies for young people like you and I
have a few dummies like
and we are talking about the needs for
relationships yes they are talking about
my worry about people being lonely yes
it's my worry about you young people
being on your iPhone's it's too much
said of having the talking face to face
instead of the art of conversations
people are going to lose that dr. Ruth
you're speaking my language because I
think that is the I'm so I watched your
story and I watched your you've you had
two marriages before you're you're the
love of your life and but you had great
romances in your life and it just seems
like the courtship that was there and
and you describing meeting these men and
falling in love and it just doesn't
happen that way anymore and I'm so
frustrated by it because I want that too
I've been saying all I want is to get
into a relationship and we don't have to
get married but can we just have a lot
of we fall in love with each other and
roll around in the haystacks like you
literally did in your document in your
life she she lost her virginity in a
haystack she rolled around in the
haystack
I'm dumbing for that I just wanna have a
bunch of sex with someone fall in love
with them but these guys are so scared
that I want to get made that of
commitment and be having their options
cut off do you think what does she has
it changed have they always felt that
way how do I get over that yeah I tell
you something that things have changed
because because of the media people
think maybe there's something better out
there it's a big problem instead of
committing and saying I make the best
out of this relationship they're
constantly looking of maybe they're
missing something and which is a pity
and I do believe that the best
relationship is one I'm not even saying
marriage I'm saying about a commitment
and we see these days not only men not
being able to commit but women yeah that
that is something a new phenomena that
women think also you know
why should I settle with this guy if
there's another one waiting in the wings
and so we have to talk about it we have
to say to people something that you see
in the media in the movies is is fantasy
use it you know in order to relax but
don't think that life is like that
that is the problem I often get back
together with an ex-boyfriend and I've
said this before because I I break up
with him and then I go date other men
and I look back at him and I go oh he's
the best I can do so I go back to him
because I'm like do it is settling such
a bad thing if you find someone that
you're like it's not perfect we keep
breaking up maybe we should just get
married and actually try to work on this
thing because maybe there isn't better
out there and maybe what we have is
special and it's not perfect but when
when do you decide to hang it up and
when do you decide to go back and
actually work yeah very difficult
because it really needs some insight
into your whole psychological makeup in
order to know that and I have nothing
against people saying all right that
ex-boyfriend let's give another chance
yeah sometimes people in a situation
like this should actually go for a short
period of time to a therapist to
behavior therapist not psychoanalysis of
all three times a week are cheap on the
cheap one some short behavior therapy to
understand do we want to stay in this
relationship or like the book that I did
should I leave or should I go sometimes
you know on radio there was a woman that
said to me she's in a relationship for
three years
they have wonderful sex they love each
other but she never sees him on weekends
mm-hmm I said is he working on weekends
no I said is he taking care of aging
parents
I said you see married and she said yes
so on weekends he's with his family
guess what I use I'm not a disc jockey
but I used one song and I gave the
engineer a sign and that song was I'm
gonna wash that man right out of my I
asked Ryan why is that zone not in my
documentary yeah I love it guess what if
they had told me I would have gotten it
for them without paying I had nothing to
do with the editing nothing to do with
the thing I'm very happy the way for the
field it's so good it is a beautiful
film it really is and and it should be
seen by people of all ages my vision but
if I had been there that song I'm gonna
wash that man right out of my would have
been high in the fame yeah that's a good
that is a great um I I think washing a
guy out of your hair now is not as
unfollowing him muting him on all the
social media so he's not constantly
popping up as a reminder maybe you're
not what is that called when you sit on
the phone and you wait people what's a
ghost a ghost thing you sit on the phone
you say that you wait for it and you
never hear from them again yeah don't do
that but don't waste your time get up
and go no either call him oh if it's a
him stop ghosting me buddy no are you
interested in continuing the
relationship yes or no and if the
question I don't know hang up why is no
more ghosting right that's a waste of
good energy so instead of waiting just
be like call up and be like hey
what's the deal are you interested in
this because I'm not I'm not gonna stare
my phone any longer and if they go click
click goodbye because then you've kind
of taken the power back and you're now
setting off on a life without them
you're cheating choosing because it
hurts to get ghost city daughter yeah
would be very happy with what I just
said because remember when she called me
a feminist yes and I first said not not
a feminist yeah and then my daughter
daughter convinced me I'm a feminist but
I know that I think it exactly but I
think she would be very happy you have
to get me a snippet of that yes people
will get a tape of that for your
granddaughter I loved your granddaughter
in the film and she did get you to admit
that you're a feminist but not a radical
feminist and of course I was I was
siding with your granddaughter being
like yes you're a feminist yes because
you've done so much extraordinary work
that has led the way for me to be able
to talk about not like I before you
walked in here I'm talking about how I
can't have an orgasm recently and it's
very frustrating and and we were going
into detail about our sex lives and and
and we're able to do that way cuz yes I
hope you saw in the documentary how
important when I say a woman is to learn
first to have an orgasm by herself if
that doesn't work go and see a sex
therapist
not for 25 sessions just for two or
three sessions to learn to learn but
don't sit there and suffer for lifetime
that is exactly what I'm doing now
because I've tried on my own and I'm not
getting there so I've started seeing a
sex therapist two weeks ago and and and
it's uncomfortable because you're
sitting in a room with a woman who's
like okay when you talk about that what
is your vagina doing right yeah and I'm
like what you want me to describe I'm
like I'm getting kind of turned off okay
like but I've never felt my body before
I feel like so many women just so
whatever works for you use it yeah and
and and go on from yeah I feel my clit
move when I grab my new boyfriend's arms
that's great that's a good sign right I
do moving you don't have to say it in
such you can you could say you really
turn yeah I think that that is really I
want and then I want you do want to get
I want to get married after seeing dr.
Ruth's story you can have it all you
truly have it all you can have an
amazing career be so educated worked so
hard have children have great loves have
great marriage and you really did prove
to me that you could have it all in them
I'm wondering as I watched this you know
Eve you've paved the way for people like
me and and and and so many other women
that to talk openly about their bodies
who paved the way for you who did you
look to and go oh I guess that's okay
for me to talk about my sexuality how
did you we're gonna come from in the in
the movie you saw that they did the
animation beautifully so god I'm looking
at a book by Van de Velde that was very
very famous at the time and they were
illustrations of sexual intercourse so
that's when I said in the animation
that's when I said oh that's what my
parents are doing so I must have been
curious even at the age of ten Wow and
that's why I do a lot of the books
because I believe that some parents
should bring home a book put it on the
coffee table leave it there that's not
my son Joel yes said that I did leave
books I didn't have the talk right yes
but parents in today's world have to you
for you especially you have to tell your
listeners that girls menstruate at an
earlier and earlier age these days we
don't know yet why we don't have any
scientifically validated data some
people say in nutrition but a girl has
to know about it a boy should also know
otherwise she gets scared so scared
family there is blood right for inner
panties blood never came from so the
reason for sex education is very clear
boys and girls have to know but
nocturnal emission about wet dreams so
that they don't get scared oh I thought
that's when a guy left in the night I
didn't even get that lesson that's a
nocturnal emission so that's why I'm
very happy about the documentary because
exactly what you just said it opens the
way for a discussion with whoever is
watching yeah I'm very happy about that
yeah I felt the same I really do
recommend this documentary more than I
can I'm just telling you guys you need
to see it I feel different today on the
way to work I was tears streaming down
my face on the train and it wasn't
because it was it is there's moments of
this documentary that are tragic and and
hard to listen to and hard to get
through with that you need to face
because it does involve the Holocaust
and it does involve an insight Auctus
ori and before you came in and so my
listeners now are probably a little up
to speed but it is it's not only that
but the way that you talk about sex it
really is so inspiring and I I look at
young kids and think about if I wouldn't
have known about my period and got it I
and there are girls every day getting
their period being like what I'm dying
right and that is that's so painful for
a young child and that sends them off on
a life of that's that's a profound
moment so try to avoid that and get in
early
leave books around you didn't have to
talk with your son you just left
literature around he got it I go see
this movie have your kids see this movie
they'll learn a lot in different ways
it's not gonna there's nothing too
grotesque about it that's gonna turn
them off or scare them sexually it's
just gonna educate them I wanted to say
about that book that you found which is
one of the greatest moments of the
documentary is that that book that you
found of your parents you found when you
were 10 that was before you you were
sent away to an orphan
to save your life when you were 10 and a
half when the Nazis were taking over in
Germany you went from Hamburg to
Switzerland Frankfurt sorry Frankfurt to
Switzerland but your parent your parents
laid the foundation for you to have this
career by having that book on the shelf
and they gave you you were able to trace
it back to they gave me that gift before
I never you didn't know you were never
gonna see them again but they were able
to give you a gift in that moment as a
ten-year-old through a book that you
found on a shelf that is responsible for
the woman who sits before us in the
career that that we have all benefited
from oh man I wrote it but she she gets
all the credit but I really was so very
very nicely and I really would like very
much for everybody to to see the
documentary because I really like it
very much
I've now seen it I don't know how many
times I had nothing to do with the
editing so it was a surprise for me
that's fine how they put it together
and I loved it it is it's one of my
favorite films I've seen in a really
long time certainly one of my favorite
documentary films beautifully done it is
truly a masterpiece and so is your life
and I'm so so grateful for you dr. Ruth
thank you so much there's just no way
that your personality is they don't go
together
they just don't you are who you are
because your dick isn't what you want it
to be and I am Who I am because I your
vagina's on what you're like that's not
what I want it to be I don't have an ass
and that's why we're a great team
don't touch me anyone okay and by the
way the girl I'm dating called out the
wart on my finger because of your video
yeah and she said have you been putting
that inside me at any point and he said
what
[Laughter]
I was a senior in high school
and I've visited my friend at Boston
College and he played football his older
brother
this big guy and he lived with these
monster guys I didn't play in the NFL
and they all had dick pumps penis pumps
wait how did you find out about these
they were talking about him there dude
Paul because they got a shower together
okay and their dicks there are a lot of
them more like white offensive linemen
and they were competing with so they
would pump up before they go into the
shower for other no I'd be great but you
know they'd wear the pump into the
shower Wendy's on your dick can breathe
huh
when do you pump before you get laid you
can pump in the offseason when you're
not and you pump in the breast
pump rooms that are set aside women in
airports up in there yeah you could
smoke in there so I go back to Florida
back to my small town I was like I gotta
get this dick poem cuz I got College
coming and I want to be ready and I
thought I could start all over with a
solid piece so I so you couldn't go
online to buy a pump I got to go to a
store gonna get a poem ha so I got it I
was all scared because there was only
one store that I can think of that would
sell the dick pump and that was a
southern exposure okay is in Fort Pierce
on us one might still be there if you go
past a fish bait store you've gone too
far
I walked in I'm so nervous
I'm a senior in high school I'm like
it's on the main road so I like partly I
was worried about people seeing my car
you know I they won't even know that I'm
buying a dick pump but anything he's
going that store for so I'm walking in
like tiptoeing you know and I went like
at a time where I thought there'd be
less car traffic you had your sunglasses
on I'm sure that was the last time I
wore glasses inside you know so I had on
yeah I had on my oakley's microwaves you
know
and again man whatever anyways so I walk
in I'm all nervous I find a pump I'm
like that seems legit and it's 40 bucks
is probably a good one and then what I
did I got all nervous and this guy had
like those earrings with the big holes
gauged gauged ears like tattoo face like
this guy's was born in this place I
think he was born in aisle two like he
was a boy at one point that grew into a
man yes so he see he's used to people
comfortable with no I dog I feel like
he's judging me because I'm worried how
people judge me so then what I did is
got gauged ears and would touch place he
would think but then I bought magnums so
I'd be like I was I said no Muslim
magnums are for me I'm getting the palm
Pro for my little dick friend you said
that yeah yeah and you go I'm getting
this for my little dick friend yeah but
to prove that I actually have a big
piece yeah
and that this isn't for me I'm gonna buy
magnums to convince you that yeah these
are for me and these this is for my
friend and I told him this whole speech
and he you're buying your friend a pump
yeah cuz he's got a little dick as a
prank you said as a partner Oh as a
prank is used yeah as a prank
oh yeah so I buy the I buy the pump
oh by the way he didn't give a like
he's heard this story before I'm not the
first little dick man to come in here
with a with a with a tail yeah so I buy
the pump I bring a bag to my dad's I use
it once maybe three times I might have
slept with it on for over a month but no
I use my dick pump a few times did work
it would give you more blood flow what
were you pumping for just Jim no no I
was just pumping the pump do you think
so it wasn't for women it was for you to
just feel poor eventually for women to
go get coffee
you would just pump it's like you lift
in the offseason in football to get
ready for season I was getting ready for
the season but I thought that it
pumps you up for a couple minutes
afterwards it doesn't like last yeah but
I didn't know that yes
then okay I just heard a big line then
say you're diggin jacked and so you're
just pumping to get ready for freshman
year of college
yeah you're gonna get so much and
you want to be pumped up yeah got it
wanna be ready to go yeah so I bring it
to college and I put it away in my bag
like in the top area cuz I don't want
anyone to find it before you know
college kids speed this story up a
little bit yeah
so I'll speed it up so I end up using it
like maybe once or twice and I used it I
was going to class I was I was late to
class lazy covers Plunkett I had to get
the pump in cuz I counted them because
I'm OCD at 69 pump I pump I put it in
the drawer I don't put it away in the
bag yeah you gotta get to class you just
threw it in the drawer I just threw it
in it'll be fine
I still remember it's like it was
yesterday like why did I not take the
time so I put in the drawer and I go to
class and then after class I go and I
smoke like gravity bong heads and
meanwhile my roommate is looking for a
lighter in our dorm room and he goes
onto my side and he opens the drawer to
look for a lighter and he saw a big
lighter that came with lotion inside it
would sharp things and with a pump
handle so it didn't like the cigarette
so he called a friend and my friend
Aaron called a friend and then he called
a friend and I swear to god they called
every girl in my freshman class the
prettiest girl all the girls I was
pumping for well in the offseason we're
in there oh no every hot girl I am not
kidding what's in a dorm room the size
of this room walk in I see my roommate
reached for the drawer I'm like that's
not your side Seth
I thought your side of the room it's not
his son what are you doing Seth go to
your side
oh no that's the drawer that I keep my
penis pump it hi it's Nikki Glaser from
you up with Nikki Glaser you're watching
a clip from our
tune in every Tuesday for a new clip
from you up with Nikki Glaser why are
you here